escribe 14 mil 897 de manera extendida
veamos la posición de cada uno de estos
números tenemos 1
y 7
7 se encuentra en el lugar de las
unidades
9 se encuentra en el lugar de las
decenas el 8 se encuentra en el lugar de
las centenas
y 450 en el lugar de los millares y uno
se encuentra en la posición de las
decenas de millares si vemos la cantidad
de ceros en cada uno tenemos que aquí no
hay ningún cero es la unidad en las
decenas tenemos 10 en las centenas
tenemos 100 en los millares tenemos 1000
o tres ceros y en las decenas de
millares tenemos cuatro ceros como vemos
cada que nos movemos hacia la izquierda
se va aumentando esto en un factor de 10
o se va aumentando un 0 ahora esto
quiere decir que este 7 de acá
representa 7 unidades
o lo que es lo mismo 7 por 1 que es
igual a 7 este 9 son 9 decenas que es lo
mismo que 9 por 10 igual a 90
el siguiente número es este 8 que está
en el lugar de las centenas representa
literalmente 8 centenas y esto implica
que es 8% igual a 800
el siguiente número el 4 está en qué
lugar en el de los millares son cuatro
millares y eso implica que este 4 se
multiplica por mil y nos da 4000
finalmente este uno está en las escenas
de millar lo que implica que es una
escena
de millar de millar y esto es uno por
diez mil que es igual a diez mil muy
bien
ahora ya tenemos cada uno de estos
números su valor por posición y ahora
tenemos que sumar estos para tener la
expresión extendida quiere decir que
tengo 10.000 más 4.000 más 800 más 90
finalmente más 7 y esto también lo puedo
expresar como esta columna es decir 1
por 10.000 más 4 por 1.000 y ya lo
pueden adivinar lo que sigue es pero
vamos a escribir lo más 8% muy bien ya
vamos por menos llamamos por menos más 9
por 10 y finalmente
[Música]
7 por 1 cualquiera de estas dos formas
se puede considerar como una forma
extendida nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo